radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene
suffered another public humiliation she
seems to have a very high tolerance for
these as she is constantly embarrassing
and humiliating herself in public
fortunately her constituents don't seem
to care let me tell you what happened
there was a hearing about extremism
white supremacy criminality so on and so
forth and one of the witnesses during
this hearing was a woman named Amy
spitalnik and she's a senior advisor on
extremism at the human rights
organization human rights first not only
did Marjorie Taylor green mispronounce
her her name which we will get to in a
moment but she seemed to once again lose
a sense of how time moves forward and
2023 happened after 2024 and so on and
so forth and when the witness tried to
explain that every single politically
motivated murder in 2022 was committed
by a right-wing extremist Marjorie
Taylor green brings up something that
happened in 2023 and as if green is a
five-year-old it's explained to her that
it's a different year congresswoman when
it comes to politically motivated
violence in 2022 every single murder was
committed by a right-wing extremist
every single murder in America was
committed by a right-wing every single
politically motivated murder was
committed by a right-wing extremist are
you sure about that are you are you
aware that the Tennessee shooter just
recently identified as a man and she was
a biological woman was she a right-wing
extremist as well lady's time is expired
I'll allow the witness to answer the
question so that was a shooting that
happened in 2023
there is no evidence as to what ideology
motivated that shooting when it there's
a lot here this is this is actually
it's it's another humiliation for
Marjorie Taylor green but there is a lot
here first of all
imagine that
it were true
that all but one politically motivated
shootings were committed by
right-wingers and imagine that the
shooting that Marjorie Taylor green is
referring to had happened in 2022.
it's actually almost worse because the
fact that Marjorie Taylor green would be
able to say well there there was this
one shooting that wasn't a right winger
it would only reinforce that the
politically motivated shootings in the
United States are almost exclusively
committed by right-wingers now it
happens that Marjorie Taylor green
brought up a shooting that didn't happen
in 2022 it happened in 2023 so it just
doesn't even make any sense but imagine
that conversation every single one of
these was committed by uh by right
Wingers well other than this one oh okay
all but one so it's still 99 it's still
not good
now it's also true that even in the
incident this year
with the Trans shooter
we know the identity of the individual
as being trans but as far as I've seen
we actually don't know the motivations
and just because you're trans doesn't
mean that the motivations were left-wing
motivations if they were I will
absolutely tell you it wouldn't change
the reality that overwhelmingly
politically motivated shootings in the
United States are committed by
right-wingers so just an embarrassment
up and down the the entire thing
um here's the moment earlier during this
where Marjorie Taylor green
mispronounces the witness's name and
then tries this hardcore questioning
which just makes her look like a
horrible person that she is a Miss
spittle neck you were talking about
white suprematomic oh I apologize
batalnik Miss batalnick while you were
talking about white supremacist and
abortion I totally agree with you
there's a lot of white supremacist
supremacists in the abortion movement
and abortionists because they have
murdered over 20 million black babies in
America since Roe versus Wade in 1973
that's on average 900 black babies are
aborted they're ripped apart inside
their mother's womb this is gagworthy
stuff from Marjorie Taylor Greene James
so I you know I would agree with you
that that could be labeled white
supremacy or we could just label it
murder and it should never be happening
so if you want to talk about white
supremacy and the abortion movement you
should really analyze that in your human
rights groups that you run as you
collect donations from people with your
non-profit because I think that is
something extremely important to talk
about yeah because Marjorie Taylor green
doesn't grift for donations right is the
right for those black babies to have
lives as American citizens the right for
them to be born the right for them to be
given a chance to live is free Americans
instead of murder you think this is
funny Miss batonik is this funny to you
is babies being murdered in the womb
funny to you because you're smirking and
laughing this is a very tough Marjorie
Taylor green I mean right now what's not
funny are the black people and Hispanic
people and Jewish people and Muslim
people who have been murdered in
synagogue in church in supermarkets in
mosque by white supremacists are you
aware that that all colored people are
murdered uh that is that is a fact that
every single color person has been
murdered that that's not unusual pick a
color they've been murdered says
Marjorie Taylor green it's not just that
people have come the question is what
are the motivations for those murders
which seems to be completely above
Marjorie Taylor Green's head or murdered
white people are murdered too murder is
not just for minorities that may be a
shock to you so a disgusting person
Marjorie Taylor green and as usual she's
not good at this she will try to make
these Witnesses look bad and she fails
that being said the people who like
Marjorie Taylor green see that and think
wow she did a really good job she really
showed that witness she really proved
her wrong
um a common sense approach leads you to
a different conclusion but a lot of this
is what can I go back to my constituents
and justify what can I go on Hannity and
claim that I did but to any thinking
person really a humiliation that
Marjorie Taylor green is even a member
of the United States House of
Representatives that's really you know
the number one thing I hear from our
foreign viewers about Marjorie Taylor
green it's not about her specific views
as deplorable as they are
it's the disbelief that she could even
get elected in this country how how does
your country elect this person and then
you go down to whatever fourth fourth or
14th District of Georgia wherever she
represents and you talk to people and
you go oh this is how
this is how